Speaker 1: Major news in the last six to 10
hours.
Joe Biden has agreed to meet with Russian
President Vladimir Putin in principle if Putin
has not invaded Ukraine at the time that the
meeting or summit would take.
Place, and this is interesting, because to
some degree, you could say, well, Russia has
kind of already invaded Ukraine and that has
different meanings depending on what you're
referring to, whether it's Crimea or whether
it's these individual explosions that are
being misattributed.
OK, we can define that a few different ways.
But the point is, if Putin does not invade
Ukraine, however, it is that we are defining
that Joe Biden has has agreed in principle
to meet with Vladimir Putin now.
Joe Biden is kind of mediocre in many areas
in this particular area.
He's particularly well suited.
And in fact, if you said, in what scenario
should we be the most happy that it's Joe
Biden and not Donald Trump?
It's exactly the situation saying an American
president has an opportunity to stop a global
calamity that will wreak absolute havoc on
our economy and on people around the world.
That this is the scenario.
This is the scenario.
Let's see what happens.
And although on the one hand, Biden agrees
in principle to meet with Putin, and there
have been reports that such a summit is going
forward.
The Kremlin denies that there are any concrete
plans for a Putin Biden summit at this time,
and so we are going to have to wait and see
what happens there, Russian President Putin
spokesman said just hours ago there were no
plans yet for a new summit, with Joe Biden
contradicting claims from the White House,
which said the leaders agreed in principle.
So that's why the headline on CNBC is.
Biden agrees, but so far, Kremlin denies and
this is going to be a this is a I would argue
this is a bigger geopolitical test and calamity.
Really than anything that happened under Trump,
I mean, Trump will say, well, no, I went and
met with Kim Jong UN and then I got him to
make these promises.
But you know, these are the same promises
that North Korean leaders have made to American
presidents for a long time.
And Trump was just so naive in that.
And I think that this is this is far, far
more than that.
And you know, at the end of the day, just
look at the markets, right?
The markets will tell you what is the bigger
calamity.
And the markets were quite calm when the entire
North Korea thing was happening.
The markets are erratic right now.
Know that if Biden meets with Putin and Putin
ends up not invading and there's no war, the
anti Biden are going to people are going to
spin this really, really hard.
You know, they're already calling him a warmonger
now, even though Biden has already ruled out
that the U.S. would send troops multiple times,
but it doesn't matter.
And if war is averted here and Joe Biden is
involved, the anti Biden people on the left
and right will say Putin was never going to
invade anyway.
You know, those 190000 troops on three sides
of Ukraine?
They were there on vacation or whatever.
Biden was just hyping it.
That's one thing that they will claim.
There was never any risk of invasion anyway.
They will say, Yeah, Joe Biden is against
our troops because he kept them from having
something to do.
I mean, it just, you know, like, absurd on
its face.
They'll say it was really Trump's friendship
with Putin before Biden that prevented the
war.
They'll say, Oh, well, Putin clearly made
some demand of Biden, and Biden accepted it
because Biden is so weak.
Or maybe they'll say Rudy called Putin secretly.
Maybe Hunter Biden's laptop will be thrown
in there or Hillary.
In some way, they'll claim it was the Canadian
truckers who convinced Putin to back off or
whatever.
Anyway, the point is they will spin this no
matter what happens against Joe Biden.
So let's try to follow the facts of what's
happening right now.
We have a very, very sensitive and tense situation
there.
My hope is there is no war.
And let's see if Joe Biden can help prevent
that.
It's not.
It's not the US's responsibility to prevent
it.
But if Joe Biden is able to actually get something
done, I am all for it and I'm glad that it's
not Trump that's being put in that position.
Let me know your thoughts.
Let me know what you expect.
And I mean, you know, things are moving so
quickly that by the time this clip publishes,
Russia may have already been invaded, it may
have already invaded Ukraine.
Let me now find me on Twitter at De Packman.
We'll be right back.
The David Pakman Show is independent media.
We are not part of some media conglomerate.
We don't have funding for the show in the
sense that some company gives us studio space
and bandwidth and equipment.
It's all just our small team.
It's it's me doing this show and our small
team producing it on a daily basis, and we
really depend primarily on you to fund our
operations.
So I would love it if you got a membership
on my website, join Packman dot com.
You'll get access to The Daily Bonus Show,
which Alex Jones hates.
Speaker 2: All the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: He doesn't like it.
It definitely makes me think of it.
That's really an endorsement in my mind of
the bonus show.
You'll also get a commercial free audio and
video stream of the show every day, six hours
before the show is made public.
Sign up at join Packman dot com.